all right welcome to
session five of classic metal class
today we're going to be talking about
we're going to do a little bit of music
history and maybe
do a little bit of philosophy with it as
well we're going to talk about mid to
late 1970s
british metal and so as as always i've
got my
my co-host i usually list him as special
guests but he may as well be co-host
scott truly here
from thank you berkeley school of music
professor
also a touring and studio musician and
has several albums of his own
uh like me a metal head since the 70s
when
we were kids and didn't quite know what
we were listening to
but but enjoyed it nonetheless you know
i remember hearing some of this stuff
on the radio and also you know somebody
was posting that kiss alive
turned some some special number like
maybe 45.
yeah and and that was that was an album
that
we listened to because one of the kids
on my block had it and then we'd go
downstairs and get our crayons and paper
and like you know make little things of
the kiss logo or i was fascinated with
ace freely the spaceman at the time so i
draw him like shooting lightning the
stuff
out of his guitar yeah and so
you know what was going on in the 70s
obviously
the people who were doing it were older
than us um you know
they were in their their 20s or
sometimes even their 30s
right they were developing a new a new
genre of music and we we talked about
um proto-heavy metal and early heavy
metal we've also done a show just on the
black sabbath and deep purple nexus
and the bands that they spun out that
we're going to talk about a little bit
today
as well but that's the early years of
metal and a lot of people focus
on that and then there's there's this
narrative that's going around and i'm
sure people by this
point in time are getting a little bit
tired of me bashing rob halford for
putting this out there but
he does do it so so i'm going to give
him one more you know little little
zing there's this narrative that so
black sabbath
and maybe deep purple and led zeppelin
start heavy metal
and you know it's kind of you know
unpopular
among the elites but it gains a
following in the 70s and then the mantle
really passes to one band
judas priest which comes on the scene in
the mid to late 70s
and transforms the sound and there are
the leaders and all the new wave of
british heavy metal basically comes out
of them
and parts of that story are kind of true
but
the story as a whole narrative is
actually false
it's way richer there's way more cool
stuff going on
so what we're talking about today is
essentially leading up to the new wave
of british heavy metal without
actually going into that we'll do some
other sessions
specifically on that and you know we can
talk
in the 70s about there being regional
scenes
so i mentioned kiss right kiss is part
of the new york scene
or the larger american scene um you know
out and out in the la there's a scene
developing as well that some of the
british bands would poach people from
you know randy rhodes taken from quiet
riot uh for for ozzy osbourne
and you know in his his band as a prime
example
um so we're not going to talk too much
about you know la and new york city or
canada where russian triumph are you
know in the 70s doing stuff
or or europe where we've got the
scorpions and except
or even japan um we're going to talk
just about britain
and why because you know
there's this intense concentration of
metal bands
in the 1970s touring around going to the
pubs
putting out albums doing doing the
things that form
the music and it's it's going to
culminate in the new wave of british
heavy metal
which is a british wave of heavy metal
right there's some bands that we can
call
you know new wave of british heavy metal
sounding outside of britain like oz in
finland
or um riot in in
you know the the west the east coast of
the united states with 77 they've got
rock city
they're they really sound a lot like a
new wave of british heavy metal band
but they're not in britain so that we're
we're looking at what's happening
in britain and the what was going on is
the earlier
proto metal and early 70s metal are
starting to
create a new generation you know in
music we don't have to go 20 years have
a generation we can have
periods of like maybe five years or so
and
what's going to happen is the the 1970s
scene is going to start using this term
heavy metal
and there is a difference between mid
70s heavy metal and then what we're
hearing in the 1980s and scott is going
to fill us in on a lot of
a lot of that stuff for those who might
be more used to
what was happening in the 80s in those
bands or all the technological stuff
that's happening in the 90s
onward so what's going on is
something that's recognizable as a genre
of music and
a set of lifestyles and i i want to i
want to bounce this off of scott
saying maybe uh not just one single
musical sensibility or sound but like a
couple overlapping ones
maybe we can say something like that is
is happening
and it's becoming self-conscious people
are saying i want to play this kind of
music
they're not just sort of stumbling into
it or you know have their happy
results they're like i want to do this
right so i mean let me let me turn it
over to scott for a second and we'll
come back to the
other musicology things what do you
think about that idea that in this
in the mid 70s and then late 70s we're
starting to hear something
something coalescing that we can
identify as
heavy metal and that people were saying
i want to play like this
um you know let's go a step
further back so if we take the british
blues invasion with clapton
jeff the yardbirds so um and
all of them said like hank marvin from
the shadows if
anybody knows um that band the shadows
was a surf band
from america right and what the brits
were always doing was
taking what was going on in america from
the records they got in so yeah
um if we take keith richards in his book
he says
you know uh mick mick always had
the american blues records and so we'd
go over and absorb it and absorb it
under ourself
of course clapton you know said you know
willie dixon
all these people and i think we should
consider that
in the british invasion because there
was a british invasion in blues
that was as a result of people from
let's you know we could say it's a
different culture england yeah yeah
right um they're gonna take uh this
these records they bought and i love
that
um this is a point in time where it
wasn't the internet
and it was about who you knew who had
money who could get the american records
over
okay so i want to preface it with the
metal thing
so we talk about the l.a scene
when we talk about you you had mentioned
like ozzie
brad gillis l.a jk lee la
randy rhodes l.a yeah um
and even not just jump ahead but thin
lizzy
scott gorham yeah so scott gorham was
taken in because
um um
gary moore had left well jerry moore had
left but scott gorham
was brought in he admits because you
know the allman brothers were big
um leonard skinner was big and this
whole you know thing of southern
american southern rock was taking over
so the europeans were
grabbing on to these musicians with a
specific sound
that they wanted but you know if we take
any of these bands
um uh well let's see let's
you know a lot of you mentioned the
american bands
we should look at all the progressions
as uh it kind of still follows suit
that they take in these records that
they get
you know if we talk about the 70s
they're still trying to import them
right you know interestingly some of the
early big
british metal bands are including covers
on their early records in part because
it was considered like well that's what
you do anyway to fill up some space
but like deep the deep purple's um first
albums have have covers on them
and then they they do continue uh covers
like the kentucky woman sawing
right ufo um come on everybody is on the
first
album that's kind of a blues standard
that they're they're uh
using but they're putting a different
sound into it you know it's getting
heavier it's getting more
hard-edged or metallic
[Music]
sometimes the songs are moving faster
you could say i i suppose
um yeah that's fair yeah
so the tempo up and um
if i can inject some kind of musical
thing let's say we have an eighth note
one and two yeah let's go forward up one
two uh i hope i can do this so it's like
one
and two and that's double right right
but then we get um i don't need to jump
so far ahead but we get the maiden
gallop
so um the basic pulse is there
but what these british bands were doing
essentially was going okay here's the
pulse
how do we make this heavier yeah um
so definitely so part of it can be
adding in
other sort of filling up the the
the space within the measures right
um and often by the way with the bass
guitar
i was going to say it too so there's
also like the bass echoing the
the melody line too you see that a lot
in black sabbath stuff
where geezer butler until there's like a
break is playing the same riff
as tony omias and and i think that
became
very common in in uh early to
mid 70s heavy metal right
i mean bands still end up using that in
the 80s
like i noticed this when i was when i
was playing bass that on
even even a really great basis like
cliff burton
much of what he's doing is playing the
uh
guitar line on the bass and then we have
of course we have lemmy who we're going
to talk about soon right who is
essentially using the bass
as a rhythm guitar but let's take um
you know uh let's up of this fair game
right okay
yeah so heartbreaker
or moby dick
and so what's happening is back here um
and
stop me if i'm totally getting off
subject but
in this in the led zeppelin studio
albums yeah
jimmy page has a low game guitar all the
time it was only live that he had the
marshalls cracked and the orange amps
cranked with the less ball
but he used telecasters and super amps
which weren't very overdriven listen to
houses of the holy
not much for gain so you're getting a
cleaner sound out of it
uh yeah actor yeah right a cleaner sound
thank you okay um
yeah absolutely so what filled it up
was john paul jones oh interesting if we
double this
boom boom boom boom boom
i mean if for those of us that have
heard that on vinyl
it's you know it shakes the house yeah
um
i mean we can talk about two besides
like the
the how how the baseline is constructed
and i don't want to get too too far into
the weeds just talking about bass stuff
although it's important in this era well
it seems like there's two
really key elements to producing the
heavy sound
one is how how much bass is is is in
there
and then the other question would be
whether the bass is overdriven or not
right
um so like with motorhead you've got
overdriven bass almost all the time
because of what
lemmy is deliberately doing with it um
but even with uh you know you don't
always have a clean sound on the bass
with some of these bands can i explain
this yeah go ahead yeah
so in the 70s um
bass players you know generally had
fender uh fender
basses i'm sorry was you know like um we
had talked that
a lot of these players say hey we used
what was available
so ampeg amps were the thing for bass
players in the 70s in the metal scene
and it was by default but they found out
because there were two bamps
if the bass players turned the volume
you put the tubes
you know uh you know everything was in
tubes back in the day
if you turn it up and you put the tubes
in distress
um you get a growl out of them yeah and
lemmy
and actually you know i wonder what
steve harris does now not to jump ahead
but um that growl and actually even
jumping to west coast america billy
sheehan early on
amp eggs loud he had that growl to his
base right he
yeah that open e strings it would growl
um
that was part of the sound of the 70s i
mean this is actually a great
sort of thing to start with because
musically when people think about heavy
metal they typically think about the
front people the the you know
singer with the long hair you know
screaming and
how is everybody you know that sort of
thing and then they think about the
guitarist and usually they think about
the lead guitarist
even though the rhythm guitar you know
in the in how riffs are going
is it really more important to the music
than than just the
person whose solos i would say in large
respect that's that's one reason why
like when it's a total digression when i
saw uh
except down at the mercy in in new york
with andy
and we could see that um herman frank
was being treated kind of like crap
by um wolf
hoffman on stage the chemistry between
them was terrible right and then frank
quit shortly afterwards and and i'm
watching i'm like how come frank doesn't
get any solos in this you know
well it's because except was at that
point in time basically
um uh hoffman and baltus you know
and you know i i've kind of felt uh
angry about that i was like they should
treat this guy better
because you know everything about ac dc
right malcolm young
and angus young make ac dc but i think a
lot of people leave
out how important the bass is in the
entire heavy metal sound
and you know having a good bassist or
having having an outstanding bassist
like steve harris you know who's sort of
like in some respects the pinnacle
um you know i mean user butler is great
but
i would say if we get if we want to get
like totally off topic here
steve harris is probably you know better
and in some respects more influential
than geezer butler however great he
he is and then ian hill would be in
there as well and we could we could go
you know through all these these
different iterations
about it um so you know that that's
it is worth talking about this in terms
of the sound of the 70s
well let's let's not abandon this yet so
okay um
in the 70s um if i can
speak from a perspective perspective
from 70 so
we had martial amps and you could turn
them up and the guitars would get a
little
fuzz on the guitar right yeah so it
would be like well
any ac dc tune the intro to you shook me
it's just guitar
there's a pretty clean marshall tone um
so if we get to gear and production
that's not going to cut it so um
i guess the classic example not to jump
totally ahead into the west coast but
um i remember growing up everybody
saying michael anthony from van halen
was a terrible bass player
who said that everyone really everyone
and i remember this is just a quick
antidote
yeah yeah that a a cover band called
diver down
came to my college and i happened to be
writing for
the the um the arts section for the
it was called the the umass dartmouth
torch right okay
so i was given a pass to come see the
show and
i actually ended up interviewing i'm
sorry i forget his name it's
so long ago the bass player from uh
diver down and i said okay so you know
blah blah blah
you know and then he said you know take
van halen one
the bass is on one side you turn it over
and listen to just the bass if you can
play that stuff i'll shake your hand
i remember going interesting
yeah because eddie was a phenomenal
rhythm player
yes you know eddie van halen's leads and
his rhythm parts
were synonymous they didn't like really
break apart but
if you go listen to any van uh any van
halen album not eddie van gaal
any van halen now um you have
uh amazing bass parts
and we felt it when he left van halen
yeah the base wasn't the same the sound
wasn't the same
the time wasn't the same and of course
the backup voltages weren't the same
so in the 70s we we really need to talk
about the ensemble
more than what happened in the 80s where
van halen records the
um for those of you that had those van
halen records
michael anthony was put here in the mix
right right
but in the 70s why do we like those
records so much
and um that's true with um ufo so the
bass player
this is this is really an interesting
point
because if you think about the wider
music scene in the 70s this is something
we're going to talk about
um you can talk about music that is
largely
sort of dictated and driven by again
singer and guitar
punk would would kind of fit in with
there as well you know usually the
guitarist is out front the bassist is
kind of in the back
depends on the band of course right and
then of course the singer is riling
everybody up
doing whatever they're going to do you
know and um
but if you look at other genres of music
in the 70s
guitarists were important but they were
often just part of the mix
so we were talking for example about
chicago earlier
right chicago the base is just as
important as the guitar in the horn
section is as important as the guitar
i'd say you know
and metal you know it winds up sort of
moving towards the
guitar and singer you know as the front
people
um but with some with some exceptions i
mean again
motorhead when you have a trio and the
singer is the bassist
you know or or in the 1980s um wasp
with blackie lawless as the band leader
bassist and singer but actually this is
a good lead in
to a question from mark uh smith uh he
said
i remember reading somewhere geezer
butler was a guitar player first when he
got put on bass he didn't
really know what to do so he figured
he'd just mirror the guitar
so that inspiration is kind of a fluke
then and i'll say this and i'll turn it
over to scott so
there was this perception in the 60s and
70s that the bass
didn't really matter as much and you
could like turn it over
to you know the younger brother who of
one of the band members would kind of
figure it out and that's actually how i
learned to play bass when i was in the
army
and there were a bunch of friends and we
were all doing extra duty because we
were being punished and we'd hang out
the wrecks
offender base and they're like here pick
this up and play it you know
i was like i don't know how to play
there how hard could it be right
so there's there was that perception and
then there were a lot of really great
you know the bass guitar was sort of
coming into its own you could say
in the late 60s and the 70s due to other
genres of music
right and the psychedelic rock you
listen to some of that stuff and it's
really
important in that and so there's all of
that going on
and then you do in fact have a lot of
bases who didn't start out as bases
i mentioned blackie lawless blackie
lawless started out on guitar
and so there's a lot of people who
transpose
you know it's a bass guitar so it's you
know you're taking what you know
and then putting it onto four strings
that happen to be you know thick enough
to cut up your fingers while you're
while you're playing them so that said
let me turn it over to scott for
some more enlightenment on this issue um
so that this is a actually a bigger
issue than you're
presenting so a few good goods so
i'm gonna take from two ends let's say
let's take um metal band x with no name
in the 70s um most of them
are rehearsing daily right
and most of them are working out the
parts the tunes somebody comes with a
riff
yeah off of it um
and what happens is whether they're
educated or not
music they'll say well this is muddy or
this part
is uh needs space yeah and
um and you know so
the band can kind of work out where the
parts are over
let's say several months there's a
there's a second thing
so we take 70s van halen ted templeton
so we have a producer now that gets a
band that has a good song
but is misdirected in how they achieve
their sound
okay so um let's not talk about ted
tesla let's talk about
um uh producer y so producer y
will say this is a great sound
don't play here and we're gonna turn
your bass amp up a little bit
we're gonna turn this down here so the
producer um
greg like you know off record i've
talked to you in the past
the producer is is pretty much
um the referee yeah right so if you take
a band like
let's say if saxon was because they're
banned
let's say you guys go in the studio and
work out the album
well there's going to be fights why
don't i have the longer guitar solo
watch my bass not as loud as in this mix
why is this
and you have friction that will delay it
and may
tarnish the thing a lot of bands bring
in a producer because
um they are the referee so hey i've got
this killer riff
and the producer might be musical enough
to say
yeah but it's not serving the tune let's
talk about
two really important british producers
i mean there's don arden right and
um you know sharon osbourne she starts
out as sharon sharon harden right
well you know right yeah yeah he puts
manager
yeah but then there's also um
uh again associated with black sabbath
um
uh roger bain right and he's kind of
he plays an important role but then um
judas priest says that that's why
rockarolla sounds the way that
it did he he he had such an
important role in deciding what went in
and they weren't
exactly happy with it in in a way they
thought rockerella wasn't as heavy as it
ought to be
you know well that's the problem so like
uh here's
the um is dichotomy the right word
so dichotomy of um
let's say greg you and i do a duo record
bass and guitar
okay and um we're not this pedantic but
well greg your base is overpowering my
guitar and i don't have enough solo
section
yeah well scott you want to be the
center of attention
so you bring in a referee yeah i
and a producer is not just a referee a
producer makes that
make sure the the um performance is
correct
they make sure the sounds are correct
they make sure
that everything fits you know the way it
should musically
but so let's say we brought in a
producer producer
um x and said okay greg
you have this great bass sound that's
unique to you and i want you to do this
here
and then you're like oh but then scott's
gonna get a longer solo
and then scott your solos shouldn't be
16 bars that should be four bars
oh then greg's getting all the attention
so the problem
with the plus and minus of producers
is the producer's intention is to make
it
um art yeah and i will call metal art
it is art oh definitely yeah um but
um and you and i don't have egos as
people but let's pretend we did
right and let's not pretend that
blackmore and all these people did not
happen
so yeah if you bring in producers
everybody's gonna be mad they might go
to the interviews to
well back when we were young circus
magazine or yeah
and they might say well the last album
was a little soft for me it was
because of this producer but the fans
bought it
and now we're you know i hate to say it
for like 30 40 years past somebody's
going
you know why this worked because x y and
z with the bass and the guitar
and this had the thing and they added
the keys in this part
and um you know it it it's an
interesting point
the 70s was very pivotal about that
because
um if we could talk about technology for
a second
um and history so in 1964
february 19th anybody correct me if i'm
wrong
it was february 19th when the beatles
were on ed sullivan
so everyone steve lucas joe walsh
anybody that plays in a band said that's
when rock and roll started
we could argue um i'm sure we can argue
elvis i'm sure we can argue all these
other people
but um what did paul mccartney his
famous line said there was no crime that
day
because everybody was tuning into ed
sullivan to watch you know
so um
1964 february is when the kind of
banting started so if we're talking
about
uh greg you might know this was burn 72
73
the the the deep purple right 72 i think
or maybe
maybe yeah it wasn't 71 right because
that was machine head
that was machine head yeah yeah i think
it's 70 72.
so if we take history um rock music
post beatles has only been around seven
years let's put that into perspective
that's
2012 or 2013 2014.
now let's say a music style started in
2014 or 13. um
and then you know uh well i don't know
what to compare it to but
you know the beatles come on ed
sullivan's show they changed the world
we're wrong that's it's 74 so it's it's
considerably later
uh burn burn is oh yeah
recorded in 73. um
yeah that's right so okay so 60
65 so nine years yeah
yeah and and you think about what else
is going on in 74 so that's
the start of the period that we're going
to talk about in musical history
you've already got you know several more
things from budgie
um we started in 71 yeah wait sweatshirt
moving along yeah somebody gave it to me
it was a birthday present it was my 50th
birthday
recently so i thought since we're doing
70s metal i i would wear that
um you know uh what else is going on you
know black sabbath is still churning
stuff out
um outside of the the scene we we have
things happening in the americas there's
there's things that are ostensibly heavy
metal
happening there as well so so you're
right yeah from
it's it's it's a very short period of
development
and so that's a good good lead in back
into the
let's concentrate on on the mid to late
70s and the british but there are a few
things
before we finish up with the bass and uh
riffs and stuff like that let's take a
few of these these questions here
yes so um
[Music]
alfonso says this reminds me of the
issue of jason newstead's base
disappearing
out of the injustice for all album which
i think was uh
88 right as guitar distortion increases
bass mimesis becomes redundant to where
they become expendable
even though the guitar isn't covering
those bass frequencies
that are more prominent to the mix and i
think that's right i mean
i think myself this is a totally
controversial opinion
that although you know actually some
some of injustice for all is still
um uh cliff burton uh playing
on the tracks but i i think that
um because they recorded some of the
stuff before um
right the alaka reaches in my view
their sort of apex with and justice for
all
they were on a musical trajectory is
becoming heavier and heavier and heavier
and faster and crunchier
in the in the thrash movement so they're
not just doing what they're doing you've
also got them reacting to
what megadeth is doing long-standing
rivalry between them
metal churches on the scene by then
doing interesting things
and i i was struck when i listened to
and justice for all i was like this is
the end of a possible
move of development and then everything
after that i really was not interested
in when it comes to metallica just like
i
i'll admit i'm kind of a snob when it
comes to this sort of stuff
scorpions love it for sting last good
album
you know animal magnetism it's it's it's
okay but it's not scorpions good you
know
um van halen i never got into the van
hagar era
you know sad to say that's right i even
saw them in concert
you know it's fair no it's it's a fair
to say
but but but there i think alfonso is
right there is not
there is base on it but the base is like
lost and you can say similar things
like with black sabbaths born again
which featured um
uh ian gillen on on vocals bad
production
on on that um it's a great album and it
got panned
and i think part of why it got panned
besides the terrible album cover
was the um the fact that it wasn't mixed
well
you know uh and the base kind of drops
out
you know um can i interject on this one
yeah and maybe you know some other
examples where some similar things
happening or the base is
just kind of getting lost so i want to
explain like why
okay so alfonso this is an outstanding
point thank you for bringing this up so
okay so the 70s
we had uh so uh we're talking about
technology now
so marshall had their 60s and 70s amps
which if you crank them up
give you a little grit and the
guitarists use that because
um as far as pedals or if you don't know
there's guitar effects that you could
plug between your guitar and the amp
but in the 70s there wasn't a lot there
was a fuzz pedal that jimi hendrix used
right
sound like he's like along the
watchtower and
um so what happened in what you're
talking about
in um injustice
is we see the emergence of the jcm 800
is a marshall amp that was the 800 was
included to the 80s version of it
the 900 was the 90s version which in my
personal opinion
is the worst muddiest sounding amp the
jcm 2000 which was 2010
or 2010 so this is a great observation
you have
because before i mean maybe you do know
this alfonso
but if if anybody doesn't hear um
leo i don't want to go on too long but
leo fender
always wanted clean amps so in the 50s
he had tweet amps for country players
but then people found out if they turned
up the nom the volume knob that would
give it
you know distort you can always do
something different than the original
developer of the technology intends for
you right so then he came out with the
blackface amps which had more headroom
so you turn it up to six
and then start getting that distortion
then he sold it to cbs
yes the cbs and
um they tried to make more clean
headroom for the guitar
right because leo fenders from fender
amps fender guitar as we know offender
stratocaster
um their thing was clean heavy room
clean guitar
don't put our tubes in distress don't
put our so what happened was
marshall the amp company and this is
very important because
um in the 70s everyone played marshalls
right i don't care uh
um eddie van halen as a side note got
uh what do you call one of those um
attenuators
you put between the wall socket and your
amp and you turn down the power
and it puts your amp into distress
sooner
which he he destroyed many amps but he
was getting the hand
so to get to the point of in of
the fall of the base from the 70s is
let's take um i don't know this is the
first sound that comes to mind
5150 yeah 86 van hagar
the guitar is brilliant but if you
listen to that record
um let's take um summer nights
all guitar intro
but if you listen to headphones it's
covering this frequency
the low is punching the high is super
high
that leaves this much for the for
michael anthony
so now we start not we we start
noticing the bass less yeah so injustice
for all is a great
example of well the bass was here the
guitar was here
but together they made this yes
so um it reminds me of something that
we've talked about before
when we're when we would you know say
some one of us would go to a show and
say how was the show
and we'd talk about one of the key
problems for mixers
is not screwing up the bass and
you know you go to some shows and you
you can see the bass is playing and you
know the song in your head you know what
the bass line ought to be
and you're like i can't i'm not hearing
the bass line you know i'm hearing thump
thump thump thump thump
but i'm not hearing actual notes where
the bass is effectively being
transformed into
a purely a rhythm instrument like like a
set of drones
and i think that detracts from it and
and it's
again it's a sign of somebody who's not
a very good mixer or somebody who'd be
sabotaging that
um you know you're correct but also it
was the trend
in guitarists so um
the first couple rat albums were good
or better than good but not to
not to bring into the you know the west
coast again but yeah
i saw rat in 87
or whatever the guitar was so
overdriven with the jcm800s with the
mods
now what i mean by mods is
guitarists would take these amps and
have their techs
put in an extra switch to make more gain
and um if you think of the spectrum this
is very important to think about
this the distinction between the 70s and
the 80s is
in the 70s you turn it up and you put up
all these frequencies the bids would be
there
the bids would be present the the um
base would be list
uh missing yeah you'd have some like you
know dirt
but the bass player would cover that
frequency what happened
in the trendy you know even randy rhodes
was starting to do it
but uh he was too early so if if these
people had mods
and you know john sykes if we take from
thin lizzy
white snake um he started having
jcmx800s if you look at it it
had two gain knobs now the bass player
has no frequency to reside in
so where the guitar was here and the
bass was here now the guitar is here
yeah where's the bass go well in a live
set
like greg said and that's where
technology
um and trends kind of
um i guess you know essentially they
made
um they created they created new new
problems in some respects
actually that's the perfect way of
putting they created problems that
weren't addressed in in the 80s actually
yeah you know it was like kind of um uh
i don't know how many of you are guitar
players and that's that's one reason why
a good
sound person i mean you'll see people
getting like credit
uh in in you know uh blogs or you know
if
they're like the regular sound person
for a band
they're an important member of the band
you know because they make the band
sound
sound i won't just say right but but
effective you were talking about metal
being art
so they are part of the artistic
production crew you could say
they're not just a roadie who happens to
like mix the boards or something
you know and i guess in retrospect when
i saw
a lot of these bands in late 80s i
remember even seeing
maiden on somewhere in time in 86.
now we heard steve harris
okay well of course you would because
he's not gonna let himself get cut out
but
yeah but you know adrian smith
i loved i i love all of iron maiden but
when it's not somewhere in time
here's what i remember from that long
ago is
i didn't hear the notes why because they
were using rockman's
which tom schultz from boston you know
like the
the first boston record with those okay
super compressed overdrive
so that's what they were using that era
so steve harris had the click
but steve harris did not have the pitch
anymore
and um that's because uh dave murray and
adrian smith were using
these the the hip um
i guess uh sound of the time which
instead of being a marshal with the mids
being completely open
and i mean for grabs the base being for
grabs
they were we had two guitars doing this
and
um it would be fascinating i guess to
get steve harris to go
what happened man fascinating to get
steve harris period
for anything just to ask who they hide
on his favorite sandwiches
or something right so you know what i'm
gonna do is we're gonna we're gonna put
this like uh
sort of very technical discussion about
um
you know the guitar the bass and stuff
like that on hold for a minute because
we're going to come back to talking
about
keyboards and drums provoked in part by
one one question that's in here and then
something that scott and i were talking
about a while back 70s to 80s drumming
how that's changing
because i want to go over some of the
the musical history and i think that'll
help to put this
into place so i divided it
the bands that we're looking at in in
britain into basically um
four categories and i think with each of
them we can identify you know like who
the big players are and who the
who the smaller players are there's the
bands that continue from the early 70s
matrix that we talked about
in the earlier episodes like black
sabbath
definitely a metal band continuing on
and and they're doing you know good work
in the mid 70s uh although according to
tony oh me read the biographies they
were getting more and more progressively
strung out and you know having trouble
uh maintaining that productivity
drugs played a large role getting
screwed over by management
them and many other bands played a large
role and then eventually you know they
got to fire ozzie in 79
and so that's kind of a nice hallmark
and so we're not really going to talk
about
um you know later black sabbath with
with dio
and and gillen and then all these other
people that like tony martin who get
brought in
because that's that's a nice ending
point for that deep purple
very important early on very influential
but by
the the mid 70s they are stalling they
they're shedding key personnel you know
gillen leaves first
uh he he felt that he never truly fit
into the band that he was always being
treated like a hired hand
and then blackmore leaves you know and
once i think once blackmore's going now
i know you're a fan of tommy bolin but i
think once blackmore and
gillan are gone it's it's really on the
ropes and
eventually they they just call it quits
um
the few remaining members of the band
lord and and pace
and and so there's there's that going on
led zeppelin
there's debates about whether they
should be considered heavy metal at all
but clearly some other stuff is metal
you know they they were influential but
they're also sort of like
you know in the in the mid to late 70s
you could say the big formative bands
are kind of like puttering out right
they need new blood if they're going to
survive like black sabbath does
or they're they're going to break up and
in led zeppelin's case obviously it
happens because of
a death uriah heap is another
really important band as is ufo uri
a heap kind of inconsistent performances
but they just keep you know plugging
along
and they they attain a sort of stable
lineup by
the the late 70s they're moving a bit
away from their fantasy
themes to sort of hard rock and ar aor
sound but they're also in concert so
they can't get away with
not doing easy living or not playing the
wizard or stuff like that once you've
got a legacy
you're kind of stuck with it ufo is
really
you know kind of a different thing so
you know you look at the first two
albums
and you can say well parts of this are
metal you know like boogie for george
metal classic right um but
until they actually get the stable
lineup they need in terms of guitarists
they're not they're not really a metal
band they're they're sort of a metal
adjacent band at first
and then they become part of the metal
scene in the 70s
and it comes with getting michael
schenckner right
from poaching him from the scorpions
before that though it's interesting do
you
you know who else they had as as
guitarists
other people important in the scene
bernie marston
he's going to show up later on like in
white snake right and
larry white who you know be with the
pink fairies but
plays for a little while in motorhead so
they're they're a band that's kind of on
the rise although by the
by the end of the 70s schenkner's is you
know on his way out
in part because he's just an
unmanageable diva
who doesn't want to play full shows and
you know is getting and
getting in trouble uh and then we've
also got budgie you know the band that
i've got right here
and they they don't get enough love i
think they're they're a trio
out of whales they have a lot of great
stuff unfortunately a lot of it isn't
available in itunes
right now i'm not sure exactly why but
they're they're a metal band and they're
touring with all these other bands
you know so there's this you can say
this classic metal scene
i want to include hawk wind in there
even though they're really more space
rock and psychedelic stuff but they're
important
because well some other stuff you could
say is metal
you know um they're important because
lemmy's going to come out of that
so that's that's like the older metal
scene that's continuing forward
then we have the bands that spin out of
these and so we have a whole new set
rainbow
right richie blackmore's rainbow first
now
it's debatable whether the stuff in the
80s is really heavy metal is
street of dreams more pop than metal i
mean it got included on like masters of
metal but i think it was almost like
getting grandfathered in
compare that to man on the silver
mountain you know
that's metal you know uh or or uh
well really anything off the first three
albums and there you've got
you know richie blackmore as the band
leader but you've also got ronnie james
dio
contributing and then you've got whoever
it is that richie blackmore hasn't fired
yet playing
these really great musicians cycle in
and out you know which included first
like all of all of
dio's original bandmates and elf bane
and all of them right yeah well bane was
an interesting one so he's coming down
from scotland
and then i know he you know pops around
and plays in a lot of other people's
bands uh you know you could say that
richie blackmore
in some sense he's kind of a jerk right
because he he'd hire people
not like him fire him but you worked
with richie blackmore then
so it meant that you could get other
gigs and you could also commiserate
about what
what a miserable jerk blackmar was and
get some sympathy
so you got and frank zappa says how you
get your name in the paper so
yeah exactly so you got you know
rainbow is is really part of this this
this scene
um what else motorhead motorhead
is a i don't know if we could call them
a spin-off band i mean
if blackmore a rainbow can be a spin-off
of deep purple
then sure you know motorhead can be a
spin-off
of hawkman however different they sound
but motorhead brings in first larry
wallace
and then fast eddie clark you know and
wallace leaves and clark clark stays and
now you've got a band that's producing a
different kind of sound
a different a different range um some
people will say oh is influenced by punk
rock yeah i guess
to a certain extent but you listen to
like what lemmy's
actually doing in hawkman and then what
he's doing in motorhead and there's
there's a continuity there
you know um we've also got coverdale and
and and white snake you know now white
snake is is putting out albums towards
the end of the 70s but first it's the
david coverdale
band the david coverdale white snake
band and it's pretty bluesy
you know um but there is some metal edge
to it you could say
now scott and i were joking about this
the other day that coverdale
didn't have seemed to have an awful lot
of imagination when it came to swing
lyrics and
themes it's mostly all about screwing
you know in one way or another
which is fine i mean exactly i mean
it's sort of like a representative of
the l.a scene in um
that's true right absolutely so like you
know
um not to interrupt you greg no go ahead
you're gonna roll
you're on a roll but um you know
coverdale
um i had pointed out to greg the other
day on a meeting that
it it wasn't you know like you know
white six slide it in
that's you know that's like spinal tap
but he had some other tunes and albums
that were just
so unclever yes right but
i will say the sonic edge you do sex
cells
right it is good music though you know
um
right so um there is a picture between
the people that
um appreciate lyrics with the music or
just the music
and not the lyrics but um anyways i
didn't get a party too that's that's
gone yeah well the other the other bands
that i was going to talk about that are
spinning out of deep purple
and so you've got gillen and gillen
produces his own uh he's got a project
that's a little bit more
fusion jazzy maybe that's where the
spinal tap
uh period about that came out of but
then he eventually by like 78 he's put
together a stable set of musicians
and he's um you know he's producing
metal with them
and a lot of it it didn't it didn't have
the um
it was sort of like the stuff that was
big in europe and japan but didn't
really make it
in in the states and and britain
unfortunately
and then there was a short-lived um
thing that came out with a
pace ashton lord and that was ostensibly
you know kind of metal stuff and
the thing that did them in is that
ashton didn't like touring so
that that was the end of that so those
are those are important spin-off bands
and then we get the bands that are
new bands they they're not spinning out
of these things they're not coming out
of that matrix
judas priest is the number one band in
that bunch if motorhead is the most
important
uh spin-off band we could say followed
by rainbow
judas priest is definitely the most
important new band to show up
and they're not really that new you know
they've been around
since really the late 60s early 70s but
they never had their their
act together um it's only in once they
actually
get an album out with rock and roll
which is a good album i i really do like
rock and roll i think that's right
yeah but then they start picking up
steam so sad wings of destiny
there's some real standards on there my
my favorite judas priest album sin after
sin hands down
actually okay um and that's already
you're starting to hear a heavier
faster more distorted sound with all
sorts of
really interesting lyrics mixed in there
you know including
clear revelation of the fact that rob
halford is gay
i mean you can't listen to raw deal with
speaking of a fire island
and all that and not that be like well
what chick is this about you know um and
then
and then we'll go ahead oh sorry i don't
want to stop but this is an important
point because
we didn't know rob halford was gay till
the late 80s yeah when he when i really
he revealed it yeah
but i remember he in the interview with
him going
look look how he dressed look look i
look at these lyrics
look at this what was there so much
denial i think
you know and that's very important as
far as we're talking about lyrics
as far as the art of of metal i agree
with you completely
it you know what halford said is the
writing was on the wall
yeah and i know the songs that well
that's what i mean
yeah yeah anyway sorry and the lyrics
and album notes
you know yeah
so so anyway judas priest yeah i mean
we're going to talk a bit more about
them
specifically in in a bit you know you
listen to the progression
then you got stained class that is
definitely
hard edge metal and then you know
they're moving
into well uh killing machine or um
hellbent for leather is still in that
70s era as well
so a lot of really important stuff going
on you know
sorry hellbent from was before british
steel i'm sorry british steel was after
that
yeah yeah okay killing machine and
hellbent for leather
same same album called the right
different things yeah see greg knows
yeah i needed the tapes back then
i know me too but i i switched those two
by accident sorry yeah well okay because
because they have they both have dark um
sort of
album covers right uh so right
sure and then you know so then we've got
judas priests and we'll come back to
them in a bit but there's some other
bands that are important in there as
well
i think it's mark who in a social media
post brought up magnum
um so they their first album comes out
in 78.
you do and interestingly if you watch
always sunny
uh charlie often has a magnum shirt on
you know
and so you listen to them and you know
they're a good metal band they're one of
these bands that unfortunately things
come together right for you know their
first album actually did
did quite well they toured with judas
priest and white snake and voiced her
cult in the 70s
so you know important band i would say
the the most important band next to
judas priest though would be
saxon saxon is is formed in 77
and their first album is coming out just
at the end of this era in
79. so a lot of people say they're much
more new wave of british heavy metal and
we will
talk about them in when we get to that
um but there's but they do have their
origins there and then there's another
band that
again things didn't come together for
quartz who i like
quite a bit and this is a band that tony
aomi was promoting
um he helped out with their managing
and mixing and stuff like that um
he did the producing their first album
comes out in 77.
it's good stuff they just it never
really catches on
they're kind of like doing doing the
wrong thing at the at the
they're doing the right thing at the
wrong time you can say and then jeff
nichols
is going to kind of put an end to it in
part by leaving
to play keyboards with sabbath so
you know you lose one of your main
players and then i think we can also
talk about
metal adjacent bands that are coming out
and they're part of the scene you know
because when we listened to heavy metal
although we had people who were metal
heads there were there are always other
bands that they were listening to
you know at one point i was like you
know there's this whole hard rock
universe
that would be whatever you'd like be
hearing in the back of some dirt bag
older cousin's car
you know um maybe that's how we need to
think about it you know
and so who would that include i i would
say that includes thin lizzy
then lizzy isn't really heavy metal
although people would kind of like
pull them in and say they are but
they're really more of a fun hard rock
band
you know um they're not really british
either
they're irish but i reckon we can let
them cross the
the irc and get in and then we can talk
about nazareth
is nazareth really a heavy metal band i
would say no
although hair of the dog i would say is
a metal
album see here the dog i'm sorry yeah go
ahead
that's a that you know that gives you
the same
you know how we always talk about um uh
you know
when you hear it when that song comes on
man
i'm like in metal zone well that's a
cool album
you know beggar's day off right album i
agree
please don't judas me you know but i've
listened to the
problems by them and i'm like well i
mean it's good hard rock but it's not
something came together you know they
had some sappy ballads also along the
way
yeah 12 hertz
exactly which which uh aerosmith covered
yeah but i agree with her the dog was
like
one of those records you could put the
needle on and
metal out to yes right yes so i
you know you know when you hear it i
would agree
that they have let's say metal
credibility
okay that's an interesting way to talk
about it so let me throw a couple other
bands at you and see whether you'd say
they fit in there i hope i
i know it but this fog hat metal
i i would say no metal adjacent
they're rock and roll yeah and they're
fun to do the kind of metal things you
would do like you know have some beers
and
you know you could head bang to it
although it's more pro i guess it's more
dancing music right
but but let me cont contradict you with
um um back in the saddle
you can bang head to back in the saddle
but aerosmith's not heavy metal
i would say that like early aerosmith is
is arguably
american 70s heavy metal like make it
i don't know make it from the first
record yeah i mean by the time that we
get into the 80s
yeah i mean they're trying to capture
the same audience as heavy metal
but they're more of a pop band you know
oh but that's when diane warren wrote
for them
okay so they had a a writer for them
diane warren wrote
for those of you that don't know she
bring in the horns and all that sort of
stuff
yeah so she wrote like 2 000 hits in the
80s
for everybody so she wrote um
aerosmith is using her stuff but
the metal part if you want to talk about
metal is a sentiment
yeah um they don't play those diane
warren songs in concert because they
didn't write them
so you won't hear don't worry because
they'd have to give her some money
so i don't play them that's a good point
part of the cut
no i i i think um steve perry says we
have such a great catalog
diane warren wrote these huge hits that
were number one for us but we won't play
them live
because well we didn't write them yeah
and um they'll play mama kin
which is a rock anthem yeah momma kin
i don't know what you think uh well i'm
willing to say that aerosmith is at best
metal adjacent
and that's a good distinction so like
they had the heavy guitars
another band that's a british band that
i would say would kind of
fit a bad company right wow they're all
metal but if you listen to metal you
probably listen to bad company
in the 70s you know you're right you're
right
it's a super group yeah yeah and we know
how
those usually turn out not super
um right another one that kind of fits
in there
the runaways now i saw that on your list
yeah now think about us elena ford is
going to come out of there and clearly
go
in in a metal direction she's part of
the 80s metal scene although i would say
she's kind of metal white
um uh joan jett
certainly hardly gets rock and roll yeah
but the band itself at the time that
they're doing
you know there's a cherry bomb and yeah
i'd say they're not metal as such
but again catching on and
you could say that they're in some
respect kind of an inspiration for
clear metal bands like rock goddess and
girl school
that are going to be part of the new
wave of british heavy metal you know
i would say um it's my own opinion of
course but the runaways
were a cbgb's rock punk band okay
but it doesn't mean that they didn't
inspire people
so um let's bring some
similarities between the two so we have
the runaways cbgb's
punk rock yelling screaming loud guitars
out of tune
yeah and um somebody feels something
from that
and takes it over to the heavy metal
idiom or i'm sorry
genre yeah um so
i would say you always talk about the
runaways to my students
we talk about um intonation means being
in tune
right so like every musician should be
in tune
but i always say okay let's take 1978
the runaways at cbgb's at a hot july
summer night yeah everybody's drinking
and joan jett's sweating
and her g-string on her guitar or her b
string is slightly flat
are we gonna dismiss the whole
performance that's what
punk is to me but we wouldn't accept it
so much from iron maiden so this is
actually a great lead into something i
wanted to talk about you know
70s metal is uh in some respects
competing
with with punk but also with other
genres of music
and interestingly um a lot of people
don't don't know this
punk and metal were often at odds with
each other you know like like when i was
a kid
i remember when i was a middle schooler
the high schoolers
who identified with punk or heavy metal
in in like the town over
you know would get into fist fights with
each other
get out like chains and right bottles
and beat each other up over this sort of
stuff there was like this
you know punk is junk metal you know
metal sucks
sort of you know division between them
and
there were at the same time a lot of
crossovers and this is more of an issue
for like
the bands that we're calling new wave of
british heavy metal so
paul diano identified as a punk singer
steve harris says
iron maiden was never about punk it was
always fast because we wanted it to be
fast
but we we actually like knew what we
were doing you know right um
tank you know algae ward comes out a
punk
he's he's uh with the damned in this
period that we're talking about right
motorhead always had kind of this is it
is it metal or is it punk
lemmy would always of course you know
say oh it's just rock and roll man
that's right yeah
but clearly it's it's uh you know it's
kind of straddling
the field and so i think there were ways
of harnessing
the punk certain aspects of punk not the
playing out of tune
but the going fast um
you know the raw sound to it it probably
worked more for like
power trios like um motorhead or
tank or then later on venom or you know
they're going to be
originators for black metal but you
could say they certainly weren't great
musicians at the start
um you know they got they got made fun
of by henry rawlins of all people for
that
sort of thing in their early 80s um
so you know there's there's this punk in
part
in the 1970s was using
they were referencing heavy metal and
they're saying this is the this is the
past this isn't the kind of stuff that
we want to be doing musically
this is dinosaur music you know you fill
up a big stadium
with black sabbath or ufo look at these
old people
you know now we're the we're the young
crowd and so
um for a lot of people especially within
the you know
sort of more educated music scene heavy
metal in the 1970s became a term of a
program
something that you would use to write
people off it's just a heavy metal band
so the revitalization here's the point
that i'm coming to make
the revitalization of heavy metal
through judas priest
through motorhead through i would say
rainbow as well
and through some of these other bands
yeah era
that's part of the story that i want to
tell that they they showed that this
this
genre wasn't dead and that even though
like deep purple might be falling apart
and black sabbath might be turning into
quite a you know crap show
with uh you know a singer that you can't
trust and
you know their music it's debatable i
mean if you've ever listened to never
say die
it is not the best sabbath album you
know
sorry what are you going to say bad
album cover too it's
horrible so yeah so it's okay
it's decent stuff it's just not sabbath
quality right exactly well put
yeah so so the dynamism of these newer
bands or newer arrangements is really i
think
an important part of this this story
that we're we're telling here
and they had to overcome you know punk
and they also had to overcome
like disco becoming the thing you know
uh in the in the mid to late 70s
a lot of music was was getting drawn in
that direction in a more
you could say poppy direction right
um so
go ahead oh i'm sorry so
to lead on to what you did so if you
talk about rainbow
so deal yeah
which to me is
on another level so it's great but i
also am a huge jolan turner fan
but i admit he's an aor person yeah
you've got the great
so when um final vinyl came out uh
you know the rainbow record final vinyl
it was the live record it included all
the singers
except um like stone cold
um and joe joellen turner
was an amazing singer i thought it was
an amazing band i did not consider the
medal
but i consider them fantastic now right
after that joel and turner put out
rescue you in 85.
um and so um what you're saying is
out of this heavy sound we still had
heavy guitars we had prettier voices
and prettier melodies oh yeah that's
that's i mean that's when we're getting
into things that are more
more poppy metal right right you're
right
i'm sorry adult-oriented rock or black
rock
but also the glam scene to a certain
extent in that the power ballad became
this really important thing
so that you know bands that were pretty
hard
at least at the start like think about
motley crew for example right
um so sweet home and yeah
home sweet home is a power ballad right
um when theater pain came out i i was
i was kind of disappointed you know yeah
i mean
i was you know motley crue and rat were
like neck and neck for me
and rant continued on putting out great
stuff
rat that some of their stuff is kind of
soft they have power balance too
as do the scorpions but oh well later on
the scorpions absolutely
yeah they never made the transition into
like this is kind of schmaltzy you know
so it didn't work yeah in my opinion
you know but they made a crossover to a
new audience but
um i'm going to interject and say
something that you all can bash me on
and greg and i joke about kiss because
we both love
kids yeah and ace freely kiss back the
70s was amazing but
we're talking about power balance on
your subject yeah reason to live
by kiss on crazy nights written by paul
stanley and desmond child
is my in my top three greatest power
ballads
ever written well you know we've been
forever
power ballads are and whether they're
really metal or not
and what makes her a good one you know i
mean
think about some of the ones that
scorpions have you know
oh those weren't so the scorpions right
some winds of change is
i mean the stuff like on um you know
from love drive up until
still loving you yeah yeah a perfect
example yeah
um that's a power ballad right it's
great power balance but if we get to
the scorpions going on so winds have
changed there's no hard sounds there's
no
like you know at least a reason to live
you know yeah yeah
and you know like you have the boom boom
boom you still have that underlying
thing and it's like it's not really a
ballad
but it's got a great melody a great uh a
section b
section meaning the verse the chorus
and to me there was a distinction
between the power ballads that were
still
rooted in rock maybe metal
it's not cold gin i know i know another
one that we could
talk about which is a terrible power
ballad on a great album
uh ozzy osbourne's so tired off a bark
at the moon
you know if you could like if you could
like burn that off of that
album it would be like an ideal aussie
album
um but oh man that was that was oh
goodbye to romance well that's an
interesting one i i think goodbye to
romance is
is way better but it definitely is a
power ballad right
can i interject for this sure i don't
need to hijack this but
no no so so randy rhodes
was a big um student of a a a
spanish composer named leo brauer and so
diary of a madman
that intro is all leo brower stuff and
it was classical guitar so um
what randy brought to the table was what
he considered
evil sounds from an older
um uh composer leo brower
and he was studying the pieces and he
brought him to ozzy and ozzy said that
sounds like the devil
you know so like the intros to dr
diamond madman that whole song is
it's it's a slow song but it's devious
it's dark
yeah goodbye to romance was also kind of
a leo brower thing
although it's a pretty melody but
randy rhodes um let's um you know as far
as like bringing the
leo brower is a 20th century composer
right a guitar
but he was so immersed in it and he
found these dissonant sounds
he brought to ozzy so
can we make it incorporating dissonance
in the right way to create a musical
effect is what you're saying right
exactly so what happened was he would
play diver madman it was dissonant
evil sounding to the but still could be
accepted by the
um sensitive layman's ears right
so at the time when that record came out
i wasn't playing guitar yet
but it gave me kind of this feeling
right
and um well in your teenage years you
have all sorts of feelings coming up
right
right right you know you're right i'm
joking around about that yeah
but like mark you make a great thing
good goodbye to romance
we're taking leo brower uh as
a hispanic composer i think i'm pretty
sure he's mexican
okay um i should know this because i
should know it but
let's say for now he's a mexican
composer that
um i studied some of his pieces early on
and what i told my teacher was like
this is aussie music and my teacher was
like
what are you talking about us this
aussie osborne
but um so we have to make a distinction
between
um heavy guitars and pitch
organization in this case it's pitch
organization where
you play on a nylon string guitar four
notes that sound
sinister i guess right
yeah so this is a good jumping off point
i mentioned that we'd come back to
talking about
how instruments are are playing a role
in this because there was a great
question early on
from mark smith saying i think the
biggest change for me and metal from the
early 70s to the 80s
is the lost changing nature of the
keyboard in metal why do you think that
changed so much so i want to say just a
few things before that
one is that there are a lot of bands
that never incorporated keyboards
until you know maybe one album here and
there so
if you think about black sabbath as a
prime example of that
it's a four-piece set they will
occasionally bring in
the harmonica with ozzy playing it or
the wizard
yeah or some some keyboards here and
there i mentioned uh jeff nichols goes
over for for a little while but it's not
an integral part of the sound
the way that you could say like you know
your rio heap and and d purple
were and then you've got in a lot of
cases you've got the two guitar thing
going on and and sometimes in the ear in
the 70s
it was viewed like the keyboard and it
was usually the organ not not
not the sort of like later 80s keyboard
that could be a substitute for the
guitar
so in your heat or deep purple you've
got an organist you've got a guitarist
they do a lot of the same
stuff although in some respects the
keyboard
for an organ is a little bit more like a
base you know it's adding more to the
to the low end but in a lot of cases the
riff is being done by by the keyboard so
in a two guitar band like judas priest
you know you don't you don't need a
keyboard you know until you get to turbo
and then it's not actually a key
guitar since right uh or iron maiden
right another two guitar band or even
some of the well some of the power trios
like budgie doesn't really use keyboards
it's you know um guitar bass drum with
one person on on vocals and same thing
with with motorhead
right lemmy doesn't really need a
keyboard
um as a matter of fact i don't know how
you would fit one into
most motorhead arrangements to make it
work
now you know there is there is a there
are quite a few bands that do have
keyboards so
you know rainbow brings that in from uh
deep purple i think i think
i kind of think that richie blackmore is
like well five piece band
you know now it's i'm in charge gotta
make it look like deep purple so
we'll do that you know i mean who else
had had keyboards going on
at the time um white suit right
um white snakehead keyboard stuff
in 87. yeah yeah gillan gillen did
in his um ufo would bring in keyboards
every once in a while but they're not
that that important it's mostly
you know four piece uh uh you know
guitar with michael schenckner
of course he's going to take center
stage and then you know bass drums and
all that
so there's there's the important whether
keyboards are important and then there's
the change in in the keyboards
and i would say one of the big changes
is going from organs
to keyboards right so here i'm gonna
turn it over to scott who knows way
way more about this stuff especially the
80s incorporation of keyboards
you know but let me ask you this though
it's sort of the jumping off point
do you think i'm right about you know
you could sub a keyboard and a guitarist
as sort of like units within a band so
like maybe if you
have a keyboardist you don't need a
rhythm guitarist you know
or do you think i'm off on that you're
not off on that so
um a few things so the 70s
um we had monophonic keyboards which
means
the keyboard could play one note at a
time not a chord so you couldn't get
like a synth and play
like a chord you played one note like mr
crowley even in 81
um there was two keyboards or if you
ever saw yes
with um rick wakeman there's like six
keyboards
because they're all monophonic meaning
they can play one note at a time
so if you took three keyboards and
played three notes it would make
uh one chord now
i think i'm guessing in about 84 we came
out with
rolling rolling came out with the dx7
which was in
[Music]
83 so now you started hearing
things in 83 84 that
um started filling more space with
keyboards
now rush is
what are we going to call rush first of
all not metal
yeah i would say that some of the stuff
they do is is metal so i'm happy calling
the metal adjacent you know the earlier
stuff is more metal
you know so i think one of the great
yeah right so i think one of the great
guitarists was
alex lyson because he was in
you know um rush was in the 70s he had a
certain role
now the 80s came out production changed
so the producer would say
here's this new sound we're utilizing it
alex
did if you listen to hold your fire if
you listen to anything after that
he started playing he stopped playing
full cords but he started playing up
higher on the neck
and coming up with creative parts to
stay out of the range of the keyboard
so guitar parts change with the dx7
um dx7 um jump
right um from alan so you notice eddie's
playing different
on these records he's not playing these
full chords yeah
he's going to be playing like this low
note he's playing some fills
um and then as oh go ahead well i was
going to say i'm thinking about like
rainbow's use of of keyboards and how
different it is in the 70s stuff
to like street of dreams you know um
different i mean there's different
keyboardists but there's different
different approaches to i would say the
older rainbow stuff is more
kind of like organ driven the way that
that um d
purple was or you think about organs you
could play chords but they
used it in a smaller range yeah so
okay think about like dio and holy diver
um that album some of the some of the
songs the keyboard is basically just
sort of like
propping up the guitar you know but on
some of them
like like rainbow in the dark i mean you
can't have rainbow in the dark without
that keyboard you know
what what is it a keyboard lick what's
the equivalent of yeah no it is yeah
it's a keyboard part but um vivian was
face
vivian campbell at the time the
guitarist was faced with uh
okay your parts can't include these six
notes in a chord right but they can
include what fits around
this which is the main riff okay so
um guitarists had to start thinking
about how they fit in
yeah yes is that if that makes sense
yeah which wouldn't be an issue if you
didn't have a keyboardist though right
well right if this was so if you're a
motley crew or
your rat you can do whatever you want
well not absolutely everything we want
but you know you don't have to like
compete with a keyboardist
in some respect well it depends you know
on the producer i have to say so
if they say if they're saying look do
your thing we'll add keyboards after
right that's different so um hey
mick do your thing and we'll make the
keyboards fit
however like when i i'll speak from my
own
experience because i i can't speak for
mick mars because i don't know but
um i have walked into some session where
they say here's drums and bass
we need you to come up with the part
this this this and then
after the fact they'll make keyboards
um fit um the parts
however i've come into they we have a
piano part
an acoustic guitar part a 12-string
guitar part a nylon string guitar part a
piano
and here's tarz and
so there's a lot of frequencies that i
have to come in
and go okay where do i fit in now a lot
of times people will hire me as a
session player
and this happened in metal bands by the
way i mean
let's not debate warrant for the for a
second but okay
but um you know without naming names
some of my friends played guitar on the
warrant
it wasn't the guitar from warren so they
would say disguise your sound and here's
the final track
you need to place your guitar parts so
it fix
the fits we're calling you because
you're one take person you know how
orchestration works
but not to digress but
um uh
what's his name uh famous guitar player
with
kell king he started with jackson brown
don henley um cooch danny coochbar
if anybody knows who danny kuchmar is he
was a big session guitar player
and he actually came to berkeley and um
hung out a year ago and i hung out with
him a little bit and i was intrigued
because he played carol king records he
played on uh don henley's
the building the perfect beast he so he
had
so his experience was a few things three
things it was
getting the call two in the morning
saying we have this guitar player that
can't play in tune can you come here now
and replace the parts
right then there was the
come here um we have charts interpret
the charts
and make music with what you hear that's
two
excuse me three is um
working with don henley through the
billing the proof perfect b so
what i asked him was what's the
difference
you know i've had a lot of session work
but not like danny kuchmar
who's a complete legend and had been on
more records than i probably
own um and he said you know
he downplayed it but he said with don
henley's building the perfect bc you
know down at the sunset grill
yeah we're not talking about metal right
now but we're talking about a hired gun
that was like come in and it was like
the producer would say okay the horns
are going to do this
the keyboards are going to do that and
what do you got
so he said i had to really think quick
then yeah yeah
so with the to answer your question in
the 70s that wasn't so much because
those monophonic keyboards
if you had piano that's one thing but
you have the band you would add
textures of keyboard over it in the 80s
it became
keyboards are the now the producers said
the kids like the keyboards right right
yeah and you need to adapt to it
and for the guitar players that could
not play it
um that's what the producers were for
they would sing parts say you need to
play these notes lower
don't have a four note chord have a two
note chord and it was up to the
i'm just speaking guitar actually um
where you're gonna fit into the mix and
that's where you what you see in turbo
i think turbo
for priest i think that was more of a um
you do your thing and we're gonna add
these cool zany effects the kids like
like before the course of turbo
um you know um yeah that's
you know we're definitely have to do a
show on that sort of stuff like like
turbo somewhere in time other albums
where
some of the fans are like what the hell
is this you know and it's still
controversial today
but we do have to to ramp up um
i do want to read one of the uh things
that alfonso said organs and keyboards
can cover so much range they have to be
utilized carefully
in rock there is flexibility and
presence because they can blend from the
background to lead depending on the
arrangement and keyboard instrument at
hand
i think that's quite right yeah there
was another thing i wanted to read
as well from mark that that'll be a good
launching point for
bringing this discussion to a close
everyone gives kiss
nonsense for the disco you know in the
dynasty album
right but there's some of it in other
bands too early except for example
even some scorpion songs have disco
vibes and i would say with the scorpions
it's not actually disco
they like doing stuff that's kind of
reggae you know
you listen to some of their their uh or
two-tone or whatever whatever
however you want to describe that genre
i know what you're saying i know what
you're saying yeah and they were doing
it
you know from they were doing that in
the early 70s on a few of their songs
where you're like wow this is uh this is
some trippy stuff you know
right i think mark is right that um
there was
you know not everybody was was like well
disco just sucks we need to play
hard edge you know straightforward four
four
you know whatever whatever it's gonna be
there there was adaptation and then we
could also talk about like in her
early heavy metal another genre that
that
feeds into it that you can hear and kiss
and you can hear a motorhead
boogie woogie right you know that sort
of shuffle
sound to it that's uh you know that
that's
well of course they're that's there in
fog at two that's that's playing
an important role so it's not as if
there's like a pure
we only do metal this way sort of thing
i think i think metal has has always
been kind of
uh adaptive in that well uh
remember that you know let's take the
70s
where we said um rock was only 10 years
old let's say
but these these musicians all owned
records
and listened to the radio as they grew
up right and went to clubs where they
saw other people performing
and interacted with them it wasn't as if
there was just a heavy metal scene
that that's it yeah um i wanted to say
something about i'm trying to find the
comment you just said
oh is it mark or the yeah it was the one
you just read from mark
about everyone giving kiss nonsense for
the disco so let's talk about that
uh dynasty record um
it's actually pretty good shandy
that's on that one yeah yeah
shandy's an amazing tune that i swear
joe walsh stole
from it i mean it's best known for i was
made for loving you
you know okay but okay that was the cl
that was the studio 54 hit
yeah what about sure know something what
a great freaking right
right right yeah i mean i love that
record
and you know um
we have to talk about production and era
so
they went in and the record company says
you need to do what the kids are liking
now student 54 in america
is actually it was studio 54 then around
then but like it's
you know disco's taking over the uh the
americas so let's do gene's gonna do the
two
two part like the two beat bass thing
but um
sure no something is absolutely a great
tune
shandy certainly that's fantastic
writing actually if you listen to the
melody and the corns
that's paul stanley going i can write a
tune
um so the production might be a little
different but dynasty was a great record
so we could take dynasty right now and
say hey paul
gene and whoever's in the band we're
going to take these songs and we're
going to make them heavy
we'll keep the same melodies the same
chords but we're going to change
yeah yeah and there you have so it's a
matter of taking songs paul wrote
and the producer or whoever going well
let's make it more disco okay so instead
of
do do do do do do do it
so it's it's a subtle difference but um
you know sure know something is is a as
a classic to me anyway i don't know how
you feel
yeah you know if you think about it i
mean kiss in that era
also made the solo albums right where
each one had their own thing and when
you listen to gene simmons man it's all
over the map
it's completely the most all over the
map worn yeah
totally yeah i mean some cool stuff came
out came out of those albums
well the paul stanley one was unreal
well the israeli one too yeah those two
are my favorite ones
yeah um so we're gonna have to do one
about american metal in the 70s as well
and we'll hash
out whether you know aerosmith could be
considered metal adjacent or not but
kevin kiss and some of these other bands
we'll definitely
talk about those so this is a good good
chance to bring things to a close
um right we put in an hour and a half of
and we did cover the things we wanted to
cover hopefully everyone's got a better
sense
of what was going on in the 70s
that was you know moving us towards the
the sort of like almost like
you know the 70s was a great period the
80s metal just
explodes and so we're going to talk
about that in a number of sessions later
on as well
but i do want to say that what we've
accomplished today is
the um american to british
invasion to american to the west coast
to this
and then i guess essentially in the 80s
they're kind of doing this because of
technology and production
yeah and also because of uh a lot of
bands
from britain poaching american uh
musicians and so you know you can get
kind of hybrids
after a while ozzy osbourne is not
really a british band
it's just ozzy and then whoever he
happens to have hired
from l.a exactly well or or bob daisley
you know from
right exactly yeah um and a lot of that
depends on who who sharon was
was willing to allow it and then i will
give some insight first
hand to that in the future okay again
um uh i have firsthand you know um
let's say antidotes from uh carmen apace
oh and it's not stuff that if i expose
it it's wrong
but it's stuff that it's probably not
stuff that anybody who who knows
anything about
how the osborne's treated lee curse lake
and bob daisley and people or j
lee oh right right that it would be a
huge surprise to them right
we have so many topics to get on it's
it's such a great subject that you've
come up with greg this is great
well thanks thanks for being here i'm
always glad to
you know we always have great
conversations we get good good questions
and
comments great questions attending yeah
people can
we should let everybody get on with
their day and uh thanks to scott for
for joining us again thanks to everybody
who showed up to ask
questions and give comments and we'll
come up with some some new
topics we're always we always have more
topics than we can ever get to
uh but that's because it's a vast
musical world out there so
i'll see everybody hope you have a great
rest of the the weekend
and uh you know rock on
absolutely
you